he said you're the fifth best center in
the history of the NBA he said Kareem
Wilt aluan and Moses Malone what did you
think after hearing that let's just get
it straight to get me off that I had to
learn how to see if there's some truth
in the criticism I disagree however Kim
yes Wilt only because he has more points
than me that's the only thing that
upsets me about my career because he has
more points I'll let that slide I'm the
most Dominic Center ever I don't ever
want to hear another name again so that
would put me at number three I pass toim
Elijah one up Moses was alone I passed
him up four five six years ago before I
retired me I will put myself at number
three